[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRYAN JARR: Hi, guys.
ANDERS MILLER: We'll
do-- hi, guys.
BRYAN JARR: Hello.
Hi, guys.
ANDERS MILLER: Hey, I'm Anders
Miller, from Pike Place Fish
Company in Seattle.
BRYAN JARR: And I'm
Bryan Jarr.
I'm co-author on the book.
And this, who should we
name this, the salmon?
It's a real star.
AUDIENCE: Sam.
BRYAN JARR: Sam the salmon.
ANDERS MILLER: Sam the salmon.
BRYAN JARR: There we go.
ANDERS MILLER: Thanks for
having us, you guys.
This is awesome.
You guys have a great campus.
And we're really happy
to be here.
BRYAN JARR: We're going to throw
the fish to get started.
Just to let you know, I'm not
a professional fish thrower.
He is.
So check it out.
I could mess up.
It could be funny, like
the blooper reel.
Ready?
TT with the GoPro.
ANDERS MILLER: TT
with the GoPro.
BOTH: Heyah.
ANDERS MILLER: Back Jack.
BRYAN JARR: Back Jack.
BOTH: Heyah.
Do the old twister.
BRYAN JARR: OK, twister.
ANDERS MILLER: The
GoPro twister.
BRYAN JARR: TT with
the GoPro twister.
ANDERS MILLER: TT with
BOTH: Heyah.
the GoPro twister.
BOTH: [SLOW MOTION]
Heyah.
ANDERS MILLER: Back
Jack, back Jack.
BOTH: Heyah!
ANDERS MILLER: [SLOW MOTION]
Back Jack, back Jack, heyah.
BRYAN JARR: OK, now we
need some volunteers
who want to do that.
ANDERS MILLER: Is there anybody
who's bucket list
includes catching a salmon?
BRYAN JARR: We've got some
people out here.
ANDERS MILLER: Come
on up, you guys.
Yeah, come on up.
You can wipe your hands when
you're done and everything.
BRYAN JARR: Come over
here first.
ANDERS MILLER: We've
got towels.
BRYAN JARR: You're athletic.
ANDERS MILLER: We thought
of everything.
BRYAN JARR: No, you're
over here.
ANDERS MILLER: Yeah, you
guys go over there.
Bryan's going to be the coach.
BRYAN JARR: You're--
stand here.
ANDERS MILLER: And I'll
be throwing, since
I do it for a living.
BRYAN JARR: All the
way over here.
All the way over there.
OK, do not cross this line.
ARTUR: OK.
BRYAN JARR: If you cross the
line, I hit you like that,
with the fish, with the GoPro.
OK?
ARTUR: OK.
BRYAN JARR: Ready?
So this is going to come--
It's coming the other
way, right?
It's going to come at you.
Here.
Shoop.
OK, you want to bend your
legs like this.
You play video games?
ARTUR: Yeah.
BRYAN JARR: Come on,
there you go.
You can admit it.
ANDERS MILLER: Bam, grab
it like you're
playing video games.
BRYAN JARR: Keep your
thumbs up above.
ANDERS MILLER: An intense
video battle.
BRYAN JARR: Or like
catching a baby.
ARTUR: OK.
BRYAN JARR: If someone threw a
baby, you'd catch the baby,
wouldn't you?
ARTUR: Yeah, I would.
BRYAN JARR: You wouldn't
let a baby drop.
ARTUR: No.
BRYAN JARR: OK, Sam the
salmon's a baby.
ANDERS MILLER: Don't
hurt the baby.
BRYAN JARR: Keep
it, keep loose.
Come on, loose, loose.
ANDERS MILLER: You guys help me
out too, with the call and
response, all right?
BRYAN JARR: Loose video
game, catching a baby.
ANDERS MILLER: I'm going
to call it out.
You guys respond.
I'm going to call out TT.
That's a test toss or
a tourist toss.
All right?
BRYAN JARR: There we-- and--
right, a little bit like that.
Yeah.
ANDERS MILLER: Ready for
the flying baby?
TT, TT, heyah!
BOTH: Way.
ANDERS MILLER: Nice work.
BRYAN JARR: What's your name?
ARTUR: Artur.
BRYAN JARR: Artur.
ANDERS MILLER: Artur--
BRYAN JARR: Nice, I like it.
ANDERS MILLER: --there's
some wipes over there.
Clean yourself up.
We're going to send you
out like we found you.
BRYAN JARR: Who's next?
Yeah.
Oh, you've got the coat on.
ANDERS MILLER: Guys, the
response was a little week.
BRYAN JARR: Well done.
ANDERS MILLER: We're going
to do better this time.
Yeah?
OK.
BRYAN JARR: Fish juice, that
doesn't sound good
at all, does it?
Fish juice, don't get fish
juice on you, OK?
Got it?
Remember, these are going
to kind of come above.
When you catch, don't be
afraid to squeeze.
ANDERS MILLER: She's ready.
BRYAN JARR: She's ready.
ANDERS MILLER: You ready?
TT.
BRYAN JARR: TT, heyah.
Oh.
Cradled like a little baby.
You did good.
ANDERS MILLER: Good
instincts there.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I
think I'm done.
BRYAN JARR: Now you're done.
You did good.
Looky, you did good.
A little fish stuff on you.
ANDERS MILLER: That's what
the jacket's for.
There's wipes over there,
if you'd like, dear.
All right.
Back Jack.
BRYAN JARR: Coming back.
Heyah.
All right, what's your name?
MIKE: Mike.
BRYAN JARR: Mike.
How you doing, Mike?
Do you want the little
jacket on?
That's a nice shirt.
Come on, it's a nice shirt.
ANDERS MILLER: Mike, you
want the fastball?
BRYAN JARR: OK, wait,
go there.
Hey, keep going.
Don't cross this line, Mike.
MIKE: OK.
BRYAN JARR: [INAUDIBLE].
Here we go.
ANDERS MILLER: TT for Mike.
ALL: TT for Mike.
Heyah,
BOTH: Eh!
BRYAN JARR: Pro.
Bucket list done.
ANDERS MILLER: Here,
before you get all
clean, good job, bud.
Yeah.
BRYAN JARR: There we go.
Nice.
ANDERS MILLER: Come on, chef.
Ah, you ready?
BRYAN JARR: Bend the legs.
Bend the legs.
Get loose, get loose.
ANDERS MILLER: Come
on, get loose.
BRYAN JARR: Get loose.
ANDERS MILLER: It's OK.
BRYAN JARR: Video game
hands, catch a baby.
OK, ready?
ANDERS MILLER: TT,
TT heyah, woah.
BRYAN JARR: You cradled
the baby.
You did good.
ANDERS MILLER: Hey, whatever
you've got to do, right?
BRYAN JARR: Back Jack.
ANDERS MILLER: Back Jack.
BOTH: Heyah.
ANDERS MILLER: All
right, Cliff.
BRYAN JARR: Cliff.
ANDERS MILLER: He's responsible
for this whole
thing, huh?
BRYAN JARR: You've got
fish on here already.
CLIFF: They're Blue
Barracudas.
BRYAN JARR: Blue Barracudas.
CLIFF: So you want
me to stand here?
BRYAN JARR: So you want
Sam the salmon.
I don't-- wait.
Get your foot that way, Cliff.
Get your foot that way.
CLIFF: OK.
BRYAN JARR: And get the
sticker off too.
Cliff, what's going on?
ANDERS MILLER: TT for Cliff.
ALL: TT for Cliff.
Heyah.
BOTH: Yay!
ANDERS MILLER: Here, throw
it back, Cliff.
BRYAN JARR: Heyah.
ANDERS MILLER: All
right, good job.
BRYAN JARR: Anyone else?
Last chance.
OK.
ANDERS MILLER: Good
job, everybody.
So--
thank you.
How many of you guys have
been to Seattle before?
So you--
I'm sure you all went
to the fish market.
BRYAN JARR: Everyone
who-- perfect.
ANDERS MILLER: So we're the
guys that throw the fish.
Clearly, you know that now.
And we're also known for having
a good time at work.
But it wasn't always
like that.
We--
back in the '80s, actually, our
company was in big time
financial issues.
We were almost bankrupt.
And we got approached
by a business
consultant, Jim Bergquist.
And he said, let me get you
guys out of the hole.
Give me two grand a month.
I'm going to get you guys
out of the hole.
And Johnny, at the time,
he couldn't even
make his car payment.
He's like, how the heck
am I going to give
you two grand a month?
So he agreed to bring Jim on,
on a two-month trial.
See if he could turn the
business around.
And so we brought Jim on.
I wasn't there at the time.
I've been there 13 years.
This was in the '80s.
Jim's still with us now.
By Jim's whole thing was about
human beings and their power
to create things, their
power of creativity.
So what he brought into Pike
Place Fish was the
culture we have now.
Some of you've probably
seen our fish video.
Anybody seen the video,
the 17 minute
corporate training tape?
It's all over the world,
but whatever.
He brought that into
the company.
And he made us start to realize
that we actually had a
say in how our experience
goes, every life.
We get a [INAUDIBLE]
say in the matter.
So what we did is we came
up with a game that was
inspiring to us.
And he said, well, what's
inspiring to you guys?
What--
because back then everybody
was fighting at work.
Guys were crying.
Even Johnny, the owner, was
making people cry regularly.
So he came, said, all right,
we'll, let's create a game
that's worth playing so then
that inspires you.
And so we came up with
world famous.
And it's kind of--
some guys laughed at the time.
It's kind of funny.
How are you going to
be world famous?
You guys are just a little
fish market in Seattle?
And one of the guys said,
well, put it on
the side of the box.
And they said, well, you can't
just put it on the box.
They're going to laugh at you.
You guys are just this tiny
little fish market.
But made that bold statement,
put it on the boxes, did a
little more brainstorming about
what does it look like
to be world famous.
And to us it's not like a
Hollywood, up on the big
screen, and things like that.
World famous is like making a
difference for people, world
famous customer service.
If you're being world
famous, you're going
to love your workers.
You're going to love all the
people that come down.
And that kind of just
started to catch on.
And the next thing we
know, the Goodwill
Games came to town.
And all of a sudden, they
wanted to film.
And all this media started
showing up.
Spike Lee came down, wanted
to film a commercial.
And the whole thing just kind
of started spiraling out of
control, but in a good way.
And we're going, oh my god,
maybe we really do have the
power to create things.
So here we are now.
We created a cookbook.
It's just-- we really believe
that whatever we set our
sights on, we have the
power to create it.
BRYAN JARR: Yeah, and so the
cookbook really came about
over a decade ago.
They really had an idea
to create a cookbook.
And it first came about was
the second most popular
question they get.
The first most popular question
is, are you guys the
ones that throw the salmon?
Are you guys the ones
that throw the fish?
Second one is, how
do I cook this?
How do I cook that?
I even witnessed a one time
where there were three ladies
visiting, and they bought a
whole side of a halibut.
They spent $300 on a
side of Halibut.
And then as they were weighing
it, they were
like, how do cook that?
They had no clue.
And so they all-- everyone has
their little go-to recipes
that they would share.
But we really wanted to
capsulate it in one place.
Also, back in early 2011, Pike
Place Fish was one of the
first fish markets in the
country to go 100%
sustainable.
And so we really wanted to
show, OK, we can use the
cookbook as a vehicle to show
people that it's easy to cook
seafood, it's easy to
handle seafood.
These are approachable
recipes.
These aren't restaurant
designed out recipes.
And you can do it in a way
that's sustainable, good for
the oceans, and then
good for the world.
And so we're here.
We have a great one, the
Peruvian rockfish ceviche,
that we're making today.
It's awesome.
And so we're going
to be with Jason.
He was kind enough
to have us here.
And don't worry if your mango
doesn't look like that when
you cut it.
Ours would not, but
his is awesome.
So we're here to make it.
ANDERS MILLER: That's done
by a pro, right there.
BRYAN JARR: Yeah.
Ready.
JASON: You guys read to go?
BRYAN JARR: Yeah, we're ready.
JASON: Awesome.
So we have some nice local
California rockfish.
We did talk about
sustainability
a few minutes ago.
Really important, Google
green seafood.
We really have a focus on that
out here at Google and making
sure that we're using things
that are sustainable.
And we'll talk a little
bit more about
that later, I think.
But sustainability means
different things
to different people.
It's one of those kind
of catch words
out there these days.
And kind of focus on what
that means later.
So the beginning of
the recipe is--
I'm just going to make this all
together, and then I'll
show you the steps after
we get you guys a
little bit of food.
So I have the mango
right there.
It's Fresno chili pepper.
I'll leave a little bit out,
just so we can taste it later
and see how the spice
is on it.
One thing to always be mindful
of, when you're doing
something like this, is
everything doesn't necessarily
need to go in.
It says at the recipe at the
beginning, everyone's taste
are a little bit different.
And you have room to play at
the end, if you save some.
If I put all at the beginning,
I can't take the heat out.
So this gives me an opportunity
to be able to
adjust the seasoning at
the end a little bit.
This gets a little
bit of salt.
And the goal here is we don't
want a bunch of extra liquid
in our ceviche at the end.
So by getting some salt in here
right now, we're going to
let this sit while I
do the rest of it.
And then some of the water is
going to come out of these
vegetables and fruits that's
in here, so our ceviche
doesn't get too watered
down at the end.
BRYAN JARR: Yeah, if you make
all of your ceviche first,
it's really good.
But then that water is
just going to water
down all the flavors.
And so you've had a ceviche
before where you start coming
through and it's just
all this water.
But when you put in acid and
peppers and fish, all that
water starts draining out.
So we want to separate that.
JASON: Awesome.
OK, so down here we
have the rockfish.
Came in this morning.
I diced it into half
inch cubes.
And we want to do this in
a non-reactive bowl.
And that means not
a metal bowl.
The fish can react, and
we can get some off
flavors from that.
BRYAN JARR: You'll get that
tinny, metal taste that gets
on the fish if it reacts.
And rockfish, sustainable
rockfish is really good.
Snapper, bass, you can
do it with halibut.
You can do it.
There's all kinds of other
seafood that you can use.
ANDERS MILLER: It's a great
kind of fish all around.
Rockfish is like--
I will take nice Pacific
rockfish
over a piece of lobster.
It's that good to me.
JASON: Yeah, I agree with you.
ANDERS MILLER: And it's
inexpensive too.
So that's one thing we
try to focus on too.
We've got a whole section that
kind of breaks down.
A lot of people are
scared of seafood.
They think it's expensive.
They think it's going to spoil
two seconds after you get home
or if you drive home in
the car for an hour.
So rockfish, really
inexpensive and
a really good fish.
BRYAN JARR: And ceviche's
really great too.
A lot of people are like, I
don't know how to cook fish.
They're scared.
You're not cooking the fish.
ANDERS MILLER: Yeah---
BRYAN JARR: It's raw.
ANDERS MILLER: --you know how to
chop stuff up and throw it
in a bowl, right?
BRYAN JARR: There we go.
That's all you need
to know how to do.
ANDERS MILLER: You've got it.
JASON: OK, so once the rockfish
is in here, I have
some lime zest.
I'm just going to put half the
lime zest in each one.
BRYAN JARR: That smells
good-- zesty.
JASON: A little bit
of olive oil.
And we have some fish
sauce here.
And if you've never worked with
fish sauce before, go
easy the first time and learn
what your flavor profile is
for using fish sauce.
I personally love fish sauce,
but it's not for everyone.
So once again, I'm going to save
a little bit of this for
the end, so I can do
an adjustment.
Because if we get too
much fish sauce in--
ANDERS MILLER: There's
no turning back.
JASON: No turning back.
BRYAN JARR: I know fish sauce
is one of those ingredients,
when you first smell it you're
going to be like, whoa, that's
real fishy smelling.
It's not where you're
like, oh, that looks
great or tastes great.
But as it adds into things, it
just-- the flavors that come
out of it are amazing.
I was telling Jason, you know
the umami, the sixth sense for
your tasting?
Like sour, sweet, and then
there's umami, which is like
savory, earthy.
Two of the things that are
highest on the umami scale are
Parmesan cheese, Reggiano
Parmesan and fish sauce.
Parmesan's like $30 a pound.
Fish sauce is a bottle
for $1.79.
So use fish sauce.
JASON: And then the
last thing we have
here is the lime juice.
And this is actually what's
going to cook our fish.
The acidity in the lime
juice is going to do
the cooking for us.
So this isn't something we'd
want to make much more than a
half an hour before we were
going to serve it.
And as you saw, I did all
this prep this morning.
So this can all be
kept separate.
You could do most of this a day
ahead, do the fish the day
of, and then just add
your lime juice in
right at the end.
Once again, I'm going to save
a little bit of it, so I can
adjust my seasoning
near the end.
ANDERS MILLER: Question?
AUDIENCE: What's the
white sauce for?
JASON: That's coconut milk.
Thank you for--
so the coconut--
the key to this whole thing is
we're looking for a balance of
our flavors.
So we have the fish sauce,
which is umami.
We have the lime juice,
which is our acidity.
We have the peppers,
which are heat.
We have the mango,
which is sweet.
Coconut milk's a little
bit sweet.
So we're looking
for a balance.
It's not really follow the
recipe, look at their-- they
tested it out, but everyone has
a different flavor profile
for what they like.
So make it so you like it.
ANDERS MILLER: And
there's different
styles of ceviche too.
This is a Peruvian South
American version.
Really nice.
JASON: So we'll just give this
a little bit of a stir.
BRYAN JARR: And this, for us,
is a perfect summer dish.
ANDERS MILLER: So all
of us up here in
Seattle, that's August.
BRYAN JARR: Yeah,
or today would
be our summer, basically.
It's Seattle summer right
now, so that's why
we're doing it today.
ANDERS MILLER: That's why I
wanted to wear my sunglasses
during the demo.
JASON: Sorry.
ANDERS MILLER: That
looks good.
JASON: So just get this
all nice and mixed up.
And then we will go back to our
other ingredients that we
mixed a few minutes ago.
And we'll get that in here.
ANDERS MILLER: Beautiful.
BRYAN JARR: Do you want me
to grab that for you?
JASON: Yeah, why don't you
grab that for me, Bryan.
OK, and then what we're going
to do is we're going--
I'm just going to
use my hands.
We're going to lift from the
top, because we wanted to keep
whatever liquid came
off of here, at the
bottom of this bowl.
And once again, just
get this in here.
As you can see, there's probably
twice as much fish,
maybe a little bit more,
to the garnish here.
If you want to save yourself a
little bit of money, obviously
put more of this in
than the fish.
And then we're just going to
finish mixing this together.
And then we're going
to taste it.
And then that's only way we're
going to know what we need to
do to take it to
the next step.
BRYAN JARR: And when you're
mixing this, like Jason's
doing, you kind of want to mix
it and fold it together.
You don't want to--
don't go like that, because
you're not wanting to break
apart the fish.
ANDERS MILLER: Yeah,
handle like baby.
Remember?
BRYAN JARR: Handle like
baby, like you're
stepping on a baby.
ANDERS MILLER: It's the same
when you're throwing them or
when you're mixing them up.
JASON: OK so now we're at the
point where the only way we're
going to know how things
are is by tasting it.
And I really encourage this.
When you're cooking at home,
you should be tasting your
food as you go, all the time.
I talk to my cooks about this.
The only way you know
how something
tastes is to taste it.
So if you're having a dinner
party, and you're putting the
food down on the table, and
you're hoping your guests are
going to like it, best if
you'd tried it first.
Then you're going to know.
BRYAN JARR: And you can get
the guests involved.
ANDERS MILLER: I always
do that at home,
get the guests involved.
Like hey, taste this.
Let me know.
Is it good?
More salt, more something?
JASON: I like a little
more salt in mine.
ANDERS MILLER: It could use
a little more salt.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ANDERS MILLER: I could use more
heat, personally, but
that's just me, personal
preference.
BRYAN JARR: Go down
the store--
JASON: And if it burns you
guys a little bit--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
BRYAN JARR: --get a
serrano in there.
JASON: --blame him.
JASON: Yeah, and we were talking
right before, pick the
pepper you like.
This would be great, depending
on the level of heat you like,
this would be great
with any pepper.
I think this would be great with
a habanero, because it
has that really floral.
But you'd have to watch
the heat, because
one habanero is like--
BRYAN JARR: Indian
ghost chili.
JASON: --all this
Fresno pepper.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ANDERS MILLER: Make sure you
know what you're getting into.
JASON: Just going to get
a little more acidity.
ANDERS MILLER: I grew some
peppers, and I thought--
I was under the impression
that they were
less hot than a jalapeno.
BRYAN JARR: Huh-uh.
ANDERS MILLER: I ate one whole
pepper right off the vine.
I ate it in two bites,
and it was like--
it was so bad.
It was 20 minutes of torture.
Don't do that.
JASON: And when you're
growing your own
peppers, a lot of it--
the heat depends on the
soil they come from.
So the peppers that we grow here
are similar peppers that
they took over to
Basque country.
But the soil isn't the same.
So the heat's different.
It's like a Vidalia onion
versus a regular onion.
The Vidalia onion's
grown in Georgia.
There's not a lot of
sulfur in the soil.
So the onion doesn't pick up a
lot of that, and we have a
sweet onion.
Peppers are the same way.
It's where you grow something,
where the fish--
ANDERS MILLER: Where
it comes from.
JASON: --swims in the ocean--
ANDERS MILLER: Yeah, temperature
of the water--
JASON: --where the grapes
come from in your wine--
ANDERS MILLER: How deep they're
caught, all that stuff.
JASON: --all of that.
It's really where it comes from
makes a big difference.
BRYAN JARR: So you have
hot soil is where
we're going with it.
JASON: Yes, you've
got spicy soil.
ANDERS MILLER: And it's a
little bit at a time.
Because like the fish sauce, if
you throw too much pepper
in there, you're done.
You can't really take it out.
BRYAN JARR: You want herbs?
ANDERS MILLER: You could, but
it would be pretty tedious.
JASON: I'm just going to throw a
little of that on top, right
as we start putting this out.
And then I'll do the--
ANDERS MILLER: Cool, where's
our little cups?
JASON: Show you guys a little
bit of the steps I took
earlier today, after
we're done this.
ANDERS MILLER: You
guys want to eat?
Yeah?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JASON: Then the last little bit
of garnish that's going to
go on top is I just made some
popcorn this morning, made a
little cayenne salt on here.
So we're just going to garnish
the top of this with that.
BRYAN JARR: So this just gives
a cool presentation and it
gives it texture.
So this is going to
be kind of soft.
And then that gives that
crunch on everything.
ANDERS MILLER: Cool.
BRYAN JARR: Damn.
JASON: OK, so I'm just going to
move this back so you guys
can start plating, dish it up.
There you go.
BRYAN JARR: There you go.
She's going to--
JASON: So the last-- a little
bit of garnish is we have some
cilantro here.
Just going to strip the leaves
off the cilantro.
Nice thing about cilantro is
that you can eat just about
the whole plant.
Depending on what nationality
you're cooking from, they use
all the way from the roots
all the way up
through all the stems.
And the last little bit of
garnish is some Thai basil,
which is just basil, but it
has a little more of that
anise flavor in it that
regular basil doesn't.
So I'm just going to do a cut
that's called the chiffonade.
Just means "to ribbon"
in French.
See how I make that claw with
my hand, to keep my fingers
away from the blade.
The blade's always touching the
flat part of my finger.
That way I don't worry
about cutting myself
too badly, too often.
There's a little--
there's your herbs
for the top.
OK, so just to show you guys a
little bit of the tools that I
used to make this today.
Microplane, does everyone have
one of these at their house?
These are really cool,
inexpensive.
And they're great for all
kinds of things, grating
cheese, zesting citrus.
You do have to replace them
every once in a while.
They do get dull.
And you'll sit there, and you'll
be rubbing it over
something, and you're wondering
why it's not working.
A steel.
Very important to always
make sure you're
steeling your knife.
I had 10 pounds of fish
here this morning.
I probably steeled might knife
3 times, 4 times, just when I
was cutting the fish.
Makes your life so
much easier.
The blade dulls very quickly.
So to have a steel--
the way you use it, 90 degrees,
45 degrees 20
degrees, always away
from yourself.
OK?
Spoon, peeler.
So we have the mango.
The way I do a mango is
not like you see in--
I don't do the little thing
where you flip it inside out
or anything.
You can't get these
nice little cuts.
So I just take the top and
bottom off, peel it.
This is the pull peeler.
I prefer the much more than
the kind your grandmother
probably had.
I don't know.
I don't know how old
anybody is anymore.
I'm at a certain age
where I just--
could've been yesterday or
could've been 20 years ago.
So the mango has a--
the seed for the mango comes
right through the middle.
And it's kind of bulbus
a little bit.
So you're going to look right
along the top here.
And you'll be able to
see where it starts.
And you start just
about the middle.
And you kind of wait to see
where your knife bites.
And then as you cut, you turn
your knife a little bit out
and then come back around.
And you get one side.
You flip it around.
You do the same thing.
You kind of want to feel
that pit the whole time
you're doing it.
And then you can get just this
little strip off of here.
This is delicious to snack on.
And then just going to take the
mango, and I'm going to
cut it like this and
then like this.
Turn it, very similar to
how you'd cut an onion.
And then we just come through
here, keeping the tip of the
knife on the board.
If you guys see how I'm holding
the knife in my hand,
I don't have it like this.
It's not back here.
You grab the blade between your
finger and your thumb,
right here.
You wrap the rest of your
hand around the blade.
This really gives you a lot
of control over the knife.
Think of it like a hammer.
If I hold it all the way back
here, I might be able to whack
that nail, but I'm probably
going to get my
thumb in the process.
So the more you have control
over the blade--
So that's my mango.
Do the same with
the rest of it.
Lime, when you're using the
microplane, all you really
want to do is you want
to grab just the
outer peel of the citrus.
The pith, the white part
right below is bitter.
So we only go across
the mango--
whatever we're doing one time.
And you can see how I'm taking
off the dark green, but it's
still kind of looks light
green under there.
I'm not going to sit here
and go like this, see
how deep I can get.
We don't want to do that.
Just once over the outside.
Tap it out.
ANDERS MILLER: Don't cut me.
JASON: I'm not going to.
ANDERS MILLER: OK.
JASON: English cucumber,
we used an
English cucumber today.
It has a lot less the seeds
in the center of it.
It's a lot easier
to work with.
If you have a regular cucumber,
it could be all the
same thing.
Once again, I peeled
it, cut it in half.
Had a spoon, scooped
out the seeds.
Same thing when I'm cutting
this, is I'm going to cut this
into one, two equal sizes.
Then I line them up.
This-- a cucumber's a great
thing to practice on--
or something like this--
because it's long.
It's easy to work with.
They're not too expensive.
You can really work on
your knife skills.
So the first thing is, I grab
the food and I roll my fingers
up into what we call a claw.
So the blade is-- as you can
see, the blade a knife is
always going to be along
my fingers like this.
So I don't actually move the
knife, I move my fingers.
And the thumb kind
of goes behind.
We always make sure
we tuck the thumb.
And the thumb is what kind of
holds on to the food so that I
can drag my fingers
toward my thumb.
That's that.
And then we have a chili
pepper right here.
I would suggest--
I'm not going to do a right now,
but having some gloves at
your house.
Very great for if
you're working
with any kind of peppers.
These things are hot
on the inside.
They get on your hands and then
you can touch sensitive
parts of your body.
BRYAN JARR: Yeah, we just did
a video shoot and they did
have paper towels or anything.
And I was cutting serranos
for different recipe.
And then, I did not--
it was not good.
JASON: Right.
BRYAN JARR: My nose
is basically
draining on the camera.
JASON: And the eyes are the
least of your worries when it
comes to that.
So I just pulled the seeds out
and then just the same thing.
It's the same technique, just
used on different parts of the
different fruits, vegetables.
I stack it back up so I can
just come right through.
OK, so that's basically how we
did all the little steps up to
where we got when we threw
it all into the
bucket for you guys.
So, how's it taste so far?
AUDIENCE: Amazing.
JASON: Is it good?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JASON: Yeah these are all--
BRYAN JARR: OK, who
doesn't have one?
JASON: OK, over there.
The popcorn?
I made it in a 40
quart stock pot.
So I had a stock pot that was
about this big around and
about this tall.
And I just put some oil
into it, threw the
popcorn, turn up on high.
Put a sheet pan over the top
of it and popped it.
I don't have a popcorn
popper my house.
If I need popcorn, I pull
out a pan with a
lid and I make popcorn.
Yeah, it's really, really
easy to make.
You don't have to have a fancy
machine to make your popcorn.
Anyone have any questions
about the
cooking portion of it?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why the
coconut milk?
JASON: The coconut milk
is just I love coconut
milk, so why not?
But it's part of the balance
we talked about.
We have the spicy.
We have the acidity.
We have the sweet.
And coconut milk is a little bit
sweet, but it also carries
the flavors all the
way through.
It's kind of a base note almost
to our dish that we can
build on top of.
A lot of ceviche you get is very
acidic, because the acid
is in there to cook the fish.
In this one, it's more
about a balance.
It's more about achieving
that balance of flavors.
And the coconut milk really
helps with that.
And then on top of it,
it's delicious.
ANDERS MILLER: So does anyone
have any questions?
BRYAN JARR: Any questions?
ANDERS MILLER: We're
just hanging out.
AUDIENCE: Um, do you guys
permanently smell like fish
and get complaints from your
significant others to bathe?
ANDERS MILLER: I pretty much
smell like ish a lot.
I mean, my hands, it's hard to
get the smell off my hands.
It takes a vacation
with the ocean
involved for several days.
But as far--
I mean, my significant other, I
met her at the fish market.
So she kind of knew what
she was getting into.
So it's not too bad.
Plus the smell, we say that's
the sweet smell of success.
Everything I do, every vacation
I go on, everything's
paid for by that smell.
AUDIENCE: I was going
to say you love it.
ANDERS MILLER: Yeah,
you learn to--
[SNIFFS]--
you learn to love it.
BRYAN JARR: After the cookbook,
we're going to come
out with a cologne line.
ANDERS MILLER: Yeah,
great idea.
BRYAN JARR: It's going
to be amazing.
ANDERS MILLER: It's
funny though.
People actually send us a
little sample products.
And everyone's got these little
gimmicks of things that
are supposed to get fish
smell of your hands.
And I haven't really found
anything besides like going in
the ocean for several days.
Which just kind of
does it all.
Yeah, anybody else?
AUDIENCE: I had a question for
the three of you as far as--
so we have awesome copies
of your cookbook now.
But my main question when it
comes to using cookbooks is,
if you just want to make
something out of the cookbook,
but you're not in the mood for
anything specific, what is
your recommendation
on where to start?
How do you just kind of--
other than just going through
the entire book and finding
something at random, do you
start off with the main
component to the dish?
Do you start off with
how it's cooked?
What is your preferred
approach?
BRYAN JARR: I would
do component.
Or actually, if you're just
like, I just want to try
something kind of--
towards the back, there's
thing called the basics.
And it has lots of the Pike
Place seafood seasonings
broken down.
Which a lot of times, you'll
have those in your pantry.
Some of the sauces.
And then, I mean the great
thing about really good
seafood is if you bake it for
just a little bit, or saute it
for just a little bit, or grill
it for just a little
bit, and don't overcook it--
number one thing people do
is overcook their fish.
Don't overcook it.
Remember, you go to sushi
restaurant, you eat it raw.
So don't overcook it.
And then use one
the marinades.
Use one of sauces.
And that's a real basic way to
get started instead saying
like, oh I'm going to do the
clams with bread crumbs and
lemon zest and I've got to
get all those parts.
And then you can kind of move
into, you're planning a dinner
party and you're like, oh I
really want to prep for this.
But if you're just home,
go to one of those.
Usually it's just a
few basic things.
Gives great flavor.
AUDIENCE: True, thank you.
ANDERS MILLER: And creating a
relationship with somebody is
a good way to do it too that
we talk about in there.
Like how do you get good fish?
How do you know if you're really
buying what you think
you're buying?
If it's mislabeled
or wherever.
There's been issues with
that recently.
But just go find a fishmonger or
go to the grocery store and
start creating a relationship
with somebody.
And get to the point where you
could trust them them.
And go to them for
recommendations.
Because like Brian said, wwe've
got all these rubs and
all these different recipes in
the back that are a basic
sauce or seasoning that will
go on all types of seafood.
So you build that relationship
and then if
you're not feeling inspired--
I have people that come
to me every day,
like, man what's fresh?
What should I cook right now?
And then by the time they
leave, they're inspired.
And they'll grab a couple lemons
and use one of the rubs
in the back of the book.
And you're good to go.
AUDIENCE: Great, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for coming.
BOTH: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have
two questions.
First one is, are
you guys hiring?
And second question is, what are
the job requirements to be
called official Pike
Place fish guys or
gals, for that matter.
BRYAN JARR: Fish wife.
We learned the real--
ANDERS MILLER: A female
fishmonger is
called a fish wife.
BRYAN JARR: Fish wife.
AUDIENCE: OK.
ANDERS MILLER: I always thought
it was someone who was
married to a fishmonger,
but that's not it.
We--
I say we're always hiring.
You never know, so
bring a resume.
But no, we hire very
infrequently.
Everybody that works there
sticks around for a long time.
I've been there for 13
years, and I'm just
kind of in the middle.
There's guys that are 25, 26--
BRYAN JARR: 26 years, 25, 19.
ANDERS MILLER: Yeah.
BRYAN JARR: It's a career.
ANDERS MILLER: Dickie, the
boss, he just retired.
And he's been there
30 plus years.
We were all sad when he left.
We're all crying in
the work meeting.
Oh, Dickie's leaving.
And then two days later somebody
called him and asked
him to work for them.
He shows up back at
the fish farm.
We're like, man.
We're crying.
BRYAN JARR: He totally worked
the going away party.
ANDERS MILLER: Yeah, he did.
BRYAN JARR: I was at the
going away party too.
I was like-- people
were crying.
And then three days later
I'm down getting stuff.
I was like, what are
you doing here?
He's like, oh, my wife doesn't
really-- she gets kind of--
she doesn't like me
home all the time.
I was like, OK.
So now he works like
three days a week.
ANDERS MILLER: But the second
part of the question is we--
there's really no requirement.
You've got to show up on time.
We literally will take a resume
and we'll call the
first person that answers
the phone.
They come down, and they--
basically, they're trying out
for the job.
It's kind of like they have
to make the team.
We're a really tight
knit team.
Our whole thing is all about
teamwork and making a
difference.
Like how can I make a difference
for that person
over there, whether it be your
co-workers, everybody that
walks by the fish market,
whether they're
buying fish or not.
So can you work on a team?
Can you commit to something
that's bigger than yourself?
Because you're going to
wake up at 5:00 AM.
It's going to be cold
and wet out.
And you can go, well,
this sucks.
Or you can go, OK,
I'm committed.
I said it, and go make
a difference anyway.
So we're kind of looking for
people that are willing to try
things a new way and just go
have it be about the people.
BRYAN JARR: And you can't go
on vacation in December.
ANDERS MILLER: Yeah.
BRYAN JARR: I would say that.
AUDIENCE: December?
BRYAN JARR: No December
vacations.
They're slammed.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
BRYAN JARR: Everyone
works every day
for going up to Christmas.
It's crazy there.
ANDERS MILLER: Yeah, so if
you've got a Christmas holiday
you normally go on, and you
want to work at the fish
market, we're probably not
going to hire you.
AUDIENCE: OK.
All right.
Thanks.
ANDERS MILLER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
So I was born and raised
in Seattle.
So I grew up catching the plush
fish and doing all that
stuff with you guys.
So thanks for always
being there.
I just had a couple questions.
One, what is that fish that's
the chomping fish?
BRYAN JARR: The monkfish.
ANDERS MILLER: The monkfish.
BRYAN JARR: The scary
monkfish.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I remember it
scaring it when I was little
and then just laughing
at the kids now.
I'm like, suckers.
BRYAN JARR: And it's crazy now,
because when they went--
when Pike Place fish went 100%
sustainable, monkfish is not a
sustainable caught fish.
So they had to get rid of it.
And the monkfish was gone.
And--
ANDERS MILLER: That became
the most asked question.
BRYAN JARR: Yeah.
ANDERS MILLER: Instead of where
do they throw the fish
or how do I cook that, now it's,
where's the monkfish?
BRYAN JARR: Yeah.
And so they had a--
what is a company that
does things for
film and the aquarium.
And they built a $2,000
realistic looking fake
monkfish that now is permanently
at the market.
It's crazy.
ANDERS MILLER: It's
better too--
BRYAN JARR: It looks
exactly like it.
ANDERS MILLER: Because
it's got--
the teeth are fake.
And those old monkfish,
they actually had
real teeth on them.
And sometimes you can't see
what's going on down there.
You pull the string,
and someone's got
their finger in there.
So we've had a couple injuries,
just nasty monkfish
teeth ripping your finger
open is bad.
So we don't have to worry
about that ever again.
AUDIENCE: And my second one
is, what is your secret to
your smoked salmon?
I've tried like nine recipes,
and there's
something about it.
I used to work on Fifth and
Pine, so I'd always go down
there and get smoked salmon and
Beecher's mac and cheese.
It was like the perfect lunch.
BRYAN JARR: Nice, that's
a good one.
That's a good little lunch.
AUDIENCE: But what
is your secret.
ANDERS MILLER: It's a secret.
AUDIENCE: Damn it.
ANDERS MILLER: It's
in the book.
I'm just kidding.
It's not in the book.
No, it's a--
basically, it's just
a great recipe.
we've been buying from
the same people.
They smoke our salmon for us.
And I'd say the most important
factors are we always use
Alder, which is really good.
We don't make it too salty.
And we use big, fatty
awesome king salmon.
We buy 18 up.
That means they're
over 18 pounds.
They're going to be nice
and fatty king salmon.
And so if you start--
a lot of people don't want to
smoke good quality salmon.
People will buy a chum or a
lower-grade salmon, because
they say, oh, well I'm just
going to smoke it.
But we--
BRYAN JARR: And then it's going
to taste like that.
ANDERS MILLER: Yeah, and then
that's why you get a lot of
dry, seems like it's been
smoked too long.
We use big, fatty king salmon,
so they don't dry out.
So if you start with an awesome
wild king salmon in
the beginning, you're going
to end up with it.
A lot of people smoke
farm-raised salmon too.
So we don't carry any
farm-raised salmon.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
So I had a question
for you guys.
So my boyfriend's from Maui,
born and raised.
And he does not eat fish.
And my family has
a fish market.
So I'm wondering if you guys
could suggest some type of
fish that's an easy kind of
little baby step for him
that's not super fishy.
ANDERS MILLER: Something that
tastes kind of like Spam?
AUDIENCE: That I--
exactly.
He wants to eat--
BRYAN JARR: Slip it in
his Spam musubi.
There you go.
AUDIENCE: He wants to eat Loco
Moco all day, you know?
And I eat fish.
ANDERS MILLER: Me too.
AUDIENCE: I don't
eat meat, right?
So I was wondering if you guys
could suggest something with a
little bit of the island
flavors, that I can make and
kind of just trick
him one night.
ANDERS MILLER: I think some--
man, start with some black
cod, butterfish.
You ever had the black cod?
AUDIENCE: Possibly.
I eat any type of fish.
ANDERS MILLER: Yeah,
it's so good.
It's like a-- it flakes
like salmon.
It's white fish.
It flakes like salmon, but
it's really buttery.
It's almost like a
Chilean sea bass.
AUDIENCE: OK.
ANDERS MILLER: Really nice and
rich like that, but it's
totally sustainable.
You can get it all up and
down the Pacific Coast.
And it lends really well
to sweet marinades.
So that might be something.
You could go start off with
teriyaki or do like a miso.
We've got that brown--
the butter and miso--
BRYAN JARR: Oh, miso sake-- or
yeah, sake soy butter sauce.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
BRYAN JARR: Equal parts, and you
spread that on anything.
AUDIENCE: He'll never
know, right?
BRYAN JARR: Yeah.
ANDERS MILLER: No.
And then put it right on-- man,
put it right under the
broiler, until it's just
about crispy, like
it's about to burn.
AUDIENCE: OK.
ANDERS MILLER: That's another
good thing too.
If you don't cook a lot of fish,
you can cook black cod
and just cook it and cook it and
cook it, and you won't dry
it out, because it's got--
it's really healthy.
It's got a lot of
omega-3 in it.
So it's a good beginner fish.
And it's also just-- it's
my favorite fish.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
I'll try.
BRYAN JARR: Albacore tuna's--
AUDIENCE: Thanks
for coming too.
BRYAN JARR: a good one, too.
AUDIENCE: OK.
BRYAN JARR: It's sustainable
on the Pacific coast, just
because it's not as rich as your
ahi's and ones like that.
You know what I mean?
It's lighter color.
And so it just has that kind
of buttery, rich flavor.
AUDIENCE: Nice.
BRYAN JARR: Sake soy
butter though.
AUDIENCE: I'll try that.
BRYAN JARR: If he doesn't like
it with sake soy butter, then
you might want to
re-think him.
AUDIENCE: Right.
Now I [INAUDIBLE].
Thank you very much.
ANDERS MILLER: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: Hey, just a question
on other parts of the fish.
Because I know fillets
are what you use.
So what do you suggest for
the parts that you
usually throw out?
Because when I was once in
Singapore they were doing the
fish head curry, which is
really popular there.
Is there anything adventurous
that we
could do with the fish?
ANDERS MILLER: Yeah.
BRYAN JARR: We hate now
that we're people.
ANDERS MILLER: Yeah, we're
giving away secrets.
BRYAN JARR: The collars are some
of the most incredible
part of fish.
And a lot of times-- we'd always
say at the market,
someone's buying a $300 salmon,
and then the head's
chopped off, and then they
lose all the collar.
And collar is broiled or sake
soy butter sauce or with a
little bit of sauce and they're
just cooked, all the
fat and oil is in that
collar area.
And it just--
like he said, it doesn't
dry out.
It's amazing.
ANDERS MILLER: The heads
and the bones are
really good for stock.
BRYAN JARR: Stocks.
ANDERS MILLER: A lot
of oil in there.
We sell salmon heads
too, for $1.00.
Because a lot of people, they
buy a salmon and they don't
want the head.
But then we have other customers
that come by, and
they're cleaning up on that.
A guy just--
that head weighs two
pounds sometimes.
You know what I mean?
So they come get a two-pound
head for $0.50.
The bones are really good.
A lot of the meat that's right
up next to the bone is great.
Like on a salmon, after we filet
them, we'll take a spoon
and just go along the back.
You get that good meat.
You can make salmon
patties out of it.
You could use it all.
BRYAN JARR: You can use,
yeah, everything.
We've done even Dungeness
crab shells.
And then you blend the shells
up to make crab stock, like
crab bisque.
And then it's just a little
bit of crab meat in it.
But people taste it
and they're like,
oh, that tastes amazing.
And it's literally hard crab
shells keep blending through.
ANDERS MILLER: That's one thing
about being sustainable
and trying to educate people
about seafood in general is we
want-- we found that a lot
of people are scared.
And they don't really know how
to handle fish or they haven't
cooked a lot of it.
So there's a big primer on how
to pick out fish at the store,
like what you should be looking
for, how to break it
all down and use all the
different parts of the fish.
All those little tricks in there
so that it's not scary
to make fish.
JASON: I have a little
follow up on that.
ANDERS MILLER: Yeah.
JASON: So what would you say
if you didn't really trust
your fishmonger or you hadn't
built that relationship yet?
How would you go into a market
and be able to tell that
something that was
a fresh fish?
ANDERS MILLER: Well,
right here, first.
You go in there, it
shouldn't smell.
There should be--
it should smell like fish, but
it shouldn't smell fishy.
You know what I mean.
It shouldn't smell--
you know when something
doesn't smell right.
So I would say that would
be the first thing.
If you're looking at whole fish,
they shouldn't have a
bunch of scale loss.
That means that it's been
handled a lot or
maybe thrown a lot.
But yeah, so I would
look for that.
You can open it up.
Make sure if there's any blood
line on it, like a--
we always leave the bloodline
on our yellow fin tuna, so
that you can tell whether
it's fresh or not.
So I'd look for some
bloodline on there.
It should be nice and bright.
The gills should be bright.
No blood in there should be
dark brown and nasty.
You know what I mean?
Just looks like it hasn't
been sitting around
for a little bit.
BRYAN JARR: Eyes
nice and crisp.
ANDERS MILLER: Yeah.
BRYAN JARR: But then, when
you're building a relationship
with the fishmonger, if they
can't answer simple questions
about where it came from, all
those types of things, then
skip ahead.
Find someone else.
ANDERS MILLER: Same
with a restaurant.
Yeah.
BRYAN JARR: Same with a
restaurant nowadays,
especially in an area like West
Coast or San Fransisco.
If they can't tell you where
it came from, how it was
caught quickly, then go--
skip ahead.
We actually-- even when we were
just in New York, we went
to a restaurant.
And we were going through
the menu, a sushi
place, and we're like--
it was a huge menu, and it just
got cut to about this big
for us, because all of the
choices were not sustainable.
ANDERS MILLER: It was like
they were trying--
BRYAN JARR: I mean huge.
ANDERS MILLER: to be
not sustainable.
It was crazy, where I was like,
man, I don't know even
know what we can order.
BRYAN JARR: That's our next
cookbook, how not to be
sustainable.
No, just kidding.
ANDERS MILLER: But if that's
important to you too, the
sustainability thing, we
take it really serious.
It's an important thing, if you
want to keep eating fish.
So there's apps.
You can download an app
for your phone.
And we were literally doing that
at the sushi joint the
other night.
We were, OK, nope, can't
do that one.
And then it'll say, well, you
can do it if it's from this
location and not
that location.
So you ask the waitress.
And if she doesn't know,
then you probably
shouldn't order it.
BRYAN JARR: Another one that
we always tell people--
it's an easy one to tell.
So when Copper River salmon
season comes or some of these
ones that are marketed well
and known, if you go into
multiple places and it's all
about same price, and then you
go to one place and it's half
the price or like $10 a pound
cheaper, you're most likely
90% getting duped.
They didn't get some special
one they got in
at a cheaper price.
If they tell you that, they're
most likely lying.
And so if you see big price--
like oh, they always have it at
this, but these people have
it at this cheap, they're
probably passing it off as
something else.
And that's one way to tell.
AUDIENCE: So I think you did a
really great job talking about
what individual consumers can
do to make their seafood
choices more sustainable.
How about on the national
policy front?
What are some of the huge issues
facing us right now?
And what are some solutions
for those?
BRYAN JARR: Overfishing
is a giant one.
And then that's a--
overfishing--
especially, take an example
like tuna, right?
Tuna doesn't just hang out in
the United States or hang out
in one country.
It takes over the whole
Pacific Ocean.
So it has these huge areas.
And it's gotten more and more
expensive as sushi's gotten
more popular around the world.
And overfishing is going
to be a huge thing.
And that has to be a policy
on a national scale and an
international scale.
Countries have to come to an
agreement on marine sanctuary
areas where you can't fish or
fishing seasons where they
limit them.
Alaska is a really great place,
because it really
manages their fisheries, really
manages how many salmon
are caught, what the salmon runs
look like, what black cod
runs look like, when you can
do Alaska spot prawns, all
those different items.
But tuna, because it travels
so far, it's really hard to
track like, oh, we're doing
it great in the US.
But then it goes down into
Southeast Asia, and then it--
fish boats are out and they're
taking a bunch of them.
And that--
I think overfishing's going
to be a big one.
Also, a big, big one on places,
and look out for, is
how do they farm certain
seafoods?
So salmon farming's gotten
bigger and bigger as salmon's
gotten bigger.
But farmed salmon pollutes the
water, interbreeds with other
salmon and passes on disease.
They pass on sea lice.
Farmed shrimp and things like
that in Southeast Asia, they
are done in chemicals.
They pollute waterways.
JASON: It's the worst.
BRYAN JARR: Yeah,
it's the worst.
ANDERS MILLER: And they only--
JASON: They just go and
they dig a pit.
And they fill it
with seawater.
And they raise shrimp in it
until the water is too
disgusting for the shrimp to
live, and then they just move
20 feet down the beach and dig
another hole and start again.
BRYAN JARR: If you ever go out
to a restaurant, and you're
like, oh, I think I got
sick because I ate
shellfish or seafood.
I'm allergic to shellfish.
It could be because it just came
from Southeast Asia, and
it's how they produced it.
ANDERS MILLER: It's
one of the--
BRYAN JARR: It's terrible.
ANDERS MILLER: --five dirtiest
foods in the world.
And everything that comes into
America, about 2% of it
actually gets inspected.
So definitely just ask.
If they're not labeling what
kind of shrimp it is on the
menu or what kind of salmon--
If you have some awesome salmon
in your restaurant,
you're going to want to tell
people about that, because
it's a selling point.
If it just says salmon or it
just says shrimp in a dish, I
would ask, because most likely
it's naughty stuff.
JASON: If it says,
all you can eat--
ANDERS MILLER: Yeah.
BRYAN JARR: All you can eat.
JASON: --you can probably
guess that--
BRYAN JARR: Deep fried,
all you can eat.
JASON: --all you can eat,
they're probably not the most
sustainable product.
They're terrible.
ANDERS MILLER: And don't
buy fish on sale.
Go buy clothes on sale.
Don't go looking for
fish on sale.
BRYAN JARR: Yeah, but
there's a reason.
They're trying to
get rid of it.
Another good one.
ANDERS MILLER: Anybody else?
JASON: Just to touch
on Alaska.
They really-- it's like a
cooperative up there.
So when all the fishing
boats go out,
they have their quotas.
But it's not who gets back
first with everything.
It's all more of a
big cooperative.
And that's how they really
manage that up there.
BRYAN JARR: It's a billion and
billion-dollar industry.
And they want it
to keep going.
They don't want to
just go away.
ANDERS MILLER: Well, even that
one's getting a little scary
too, because now they're
drilling for oil up there.
They're--
BRYAN JARR: Mining.
ANDERS MILLER: --talking about
the pebble mine, which could
wipe out Bristol Bay sockeye,
which is the biggest sockeye
salmon run in the world.
That could be endangered.
So it's real important.
Those are important issues.
BRYAN JARR: So get
your sockeye now.
JASON: I would just say, on the
end of that, the best way
for us, personally, is we
vote with our wallets
every single day.
And if everyone on the planet
was voting with their wallets
to eat sustainable seafood,
people wouldn't be farming
salmon here.
And they wouldn't be digging up
beaches to raise shrimp in.
Those things just wouldn't
happen, because there wouldn't
be a market for it.
So I know you only seem like one
person, but it does make a
difference.
BRYAN JARR: And we always--
we talk about in the book too,
if you have a really good
piece of king salmon or sockeye
salmon, serve a
four-ounce piece and then
have other things.
You don't need a farm-raised--
it's like, oh, I got
farm-raised at this much per
pound, and I want everyone to
have a 12-ounce piece
of salmon.
You don't need that.
A, the flavor's terrible.
And if you just had a four-ounce
piece, it's going
to taste nicer.
And then we also talk about in
the book, or for seafood every
day, like clams, mussels,
those types of things.
You put that in pasta.
That's easy and inexpensive.
ANDERS MILLER: And
very sustainable.
BRYAN JARR: And fully
sustainable.
ANDERS MILLER: Well, that's kind
of one of our hopes for
the book too is we have a
national listing from doing
our books and videos and our
corporate training and all
that kind of stuff.
So we could have easily put
together a collection of
recipes, and it would sell,
because it has our logo on it.
But we actually want to educate
and let people know.
Like Jason said, you
make a difference.
Every time you make a decision
on what you buy, you make a
difference.
So hopefully we can get to the
point where it's not more
expen-- it shouldn't be
more expensive to
do the right thing.
It should be cheaper
to be sustainable.
So that's hopefully where
we're headed.
BRYAN JARR: Should we
sign some books?
JASON: Yeah, you guys
ready for that?
BRYAN JARR: Yeah.
ANDERS MILLER: Yeah.
I'm ready.
BRYAN JARR: They have to get
back to work sooner or later.
JASON: Maybe not?
BRYAN JARR: Or--
JASON: You've only been out
here for a little while.
BRYAN JARR: --beach
volleyball.
Thank you.
JASON: Thank you, guys.
[MUSIC PLAYING]